kiew heute morgen in diesem wohnviertel
der ukrainischen hauptstadt ist eine
rakete eingeschlagen
die städtische feuerwehr ist vor ort und
versucht zu löschen
innen sieht es jetzt so aus viele
wohnungen sind zerstört ein bewohner
berichtet
es gab einen knall etwas flog über uns
ich kam zum fenster und sah zunächst
nichts nach der explosion hatte ich von
dort einen guten blicken ich konnte
sehen wie fenster teile von beiden
seiten herunterfielen zum glück wurde
niemand verletzt
ein amateurvideo zeigt wie das wohnhaus
in der nacht den flyer steht die nacht
und der frühe morgen in der
millionenstadt wurden von lauten
explosionen zerrissen immer wieder
raketen beschuss die ukrainische armee
gibt an zwei davon im flug zerstört zu
haben immer wieder sirenen die die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung in der
hauptstadt den schrecken und todesangst
versetzt tausende haben schutz gesucht
den u bahnhöfen
wir waren nicht darauf vorbereitet zu
fliehen niemand hatte mit dem
kriegsbeginn gerechnet und dass sie
direkt gf angreifen würden
man wusste in der panik gar nicht wohin
und wie man sich verhalten sollte die
menschen unter schock ungläubig viele
versuchen zu fliehen dass der andrang an
den grenzen zu den europäischen
nachbarstaaten im westen bisher nicht
noch größer war mag daran liegen dass es
vielerorts schwer ist voranzukommen seit
dem gestrigen morgen rollt die russische
militär offensive von mehreren flanken
diese rakete schlug in einem wohngebiet
von kiew ein was haben die ukrainischen
streitkräfte dem entgegenzusetzen der
präsident organisiert nach eigenen
worten aus kiew heraus den widerstand
seine worte ein verzweifelter appell
ich habe 27 staats und regierungschefs
gefragt ob die ukraine in der nato sein
kann ich habe direkt gefragt alle haben
angst keiner antwortet mir
am späten abend hatte er eine allgemeine
mobilmachung angeordnet russland hatte
behauptet nur gegen militäreinrichtungen
vorzugehen doch nach den worten des
ukrainischen präsidenten aus der nacht
werden längst auch zivile ziele
beschossen
putins kriegserklärung offenbar zynismus
ziel ist es menschen zu schützen die
acht jahre einem völkermord durch das
regime in kiew ausgesetzt waren wir
werden uns für eine entmilitarisierung
und entnazifizierung der ukraine
einsetzen und diejenigen vor gericht
stellen die viele blutige verbrechen
gegen zivilisten begangen haben
einschließlich bürgern der russischen
föderation
eine blutige lüge als auftakt zu einem
blutigen krieg
ich bin hauptsächlich müde und
verängstigt es ist ein ausnahmezustand
nichts davon fühlt sich real an keine
ahnung wie ich das das einordnen
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen sagt heute früh nach stunden
der beratungen der eu staats und
regierungschefs dass der creme zur
rechenschaft gezogen werde man habe sich
auf massive sanktionen geeinigt die auf
70 prozent des russischen bankenmarkt
abzielten
unterdessen erlebt die ukraine eine
offensive wie sie europa seit langem
nicht gesehen hat